on national chess day October 12 29 teen
7:00 p.m. sharp we will be posting the
$1,000 national chess day intense chest
Invitational featuring club manager
Jonathan shruts national master Julian
Pro Rico and all the other youtube stars
and Pepe and national master Caleb
didn't be will be doing the announcing
and they asked what the heck is intense
chest alright well it's a game like
you've never seen before
it's came in one minute with a 10 second
delay it's like a tennis match of chess
and still Illustrated I got 82 dollars
cash to put up against Tracy do you
accept my guesses game a 1 minute 10
second delay it's touchmove it's intense
alright I beat you once I'll beat you
again
oh you make it too easy you make it too
easy this is not I didn't pay her $50 to
go into this so this is great this is
great this is my wheelhouse give er a
check take the pawn and now Yuri
Schulman taught me this back he's 53
naughty 2d3
where you go oh you're attack up my
knight you're a tech and my knight
what's hacking my knight
I don't not like that I thought we made
a pact like no discovered attacks you
know oh man so if I go there you're
gonna play there if you go there you're
gonna play there oh my gosh let's just
go you're just playing too fast here
okay really really really aggravate okay
are you trying to checkmate me I mean
discover mates checkmate
oh that's a ways you're the first match
that's for sure
let's just get on with the show you know
if you want three for one okay three
four one three four - I knew you were
gonna play there I knew it it's just for
the record let the record show
I get one of your guys here and
wonderful but yeah queen of the bishop
one of them's got to go
oh my gasps like this so I go there you
go there then you go there and then I go
cry is that the deal is that the deal oh
my gosh all cuz my producer Danny could
film the thing right the first time
about $32 now thanks a lot buddy thanks
a whole heck of a lot alright a little
reprieve a little reprieve here a little
whatever that means
it's intense chest I mean thinking
happen oh my god I can't beat your cuz I
can't lose about us prize before a tech
they aren't two nights the fans however
you want to call it all right remove the
defender say goodbye to the defender oh
and then you're gonna play there but
then I'm gonna play there and then you
might check make me anyway
oh my god
this is this is not I have to take I
have to take I have to take I have to
take oh you're so close where you're so
close so close let's just get on with
the show comer know it all with this
show checkmate me
it's be safe all right here we go
I get a big check but I don't know if it
even does anything but it's checked so
check shucks now that didn't do anything
do anything
magnify my losing move no it wasn't it
wasn't okay okay it's very very scary
you're covering it up I'm 1/8 seconds
away from losing 882 pucks
check
[Laughter]
this really doesn't look as competitive
as it was oh here we go master tactics
right there master tactics well there's
nothing you can do anyway so here's
comes the master tactics check
Master tactics right there all right as
an eighty-two dollars secure now for
real all right Kurt everybody join us
National just act over twelve Pepe and
Caleb them beyond the call it's gonna be
it is